[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just to clarify there ain't no technical
issues when you guys keep talking smack
imma keep it on the starting soon screen
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on guys i see you guys in
the chat man impatient impatient
get 15 seconds into this stuff and
people was like where is everyone at
where's everyone at i'm coming man i'm
coming just give me a second damn
so what's going on you guys appreciate
you coming to another attic show where
we talk about the past present future
gaming got my co-host with me hustle and
motivate
what's up
i uh paul y'all got a pardon me for uh
not being on camera today and um in the
words of frank ocean a tornado flew
around my room and i forgot the rest of
that goes but yeah it's looking pretty
bad in here i just i'm moving some stuff
around so it's just you know that's why
i said well let me just kill the camera
and i really wanted to be here and i'm
glad i was able to make it because boy
i didn't know what was about to happen i
thought i was going to have to move in
with my grandmother for like a month
while my car was getting fixed but
thankfully i don't have to do that um
thank y'all for you know letting me come
back at it i was starting to think he
was about to give me the boot i didn't
know what dirk was gonna be on today so
i'm like well damn i see he he he found
my replacement pretty quick didn't he i
said damn i said all right
it would there it's like if he available
he coming on kind of yeah now that's
that's what stopping [ __ ] with you
but now it's i'm happy to be here i'm
happy to be here hey i don't want to say
this though uh
you know i extend my thank you to you
uh that thing that y'all did with the
have the having the whole community to
submit like the short little videos i
saw and i was fired man yeah
i said i saw you know i saw a lot of
women i saw dps yeah that i can only
imagine i can only imagine no that's
super dope man we we definitely could
use some more that you know hit my line
now it's some mav work mav did some
crazy stuff
a wooden stick man like that that that
editing that he did on that was so
crazy i don't even want to think about
it yeah it's crazy he put some work in
that man i had to take a look at it i
haven't seen it yet i saw when he uh
tweeted it now i reached twitter the
form but i haven't seen it yet so i'll
catch that afterwards
uh someone wants to know is hustle gonna
be watching with you guys on june 12th
that's up to hustle he do got uh another
set of people he likes to communicate
and do stuff with uh it's up to hustle
if he wants to be part of that
who who who are the other people who i
communicate with eric
you said that you didn't you said
i'm joking i'm joking before they think
i'm serious no no um i don't i don't
know what's what's going on i'll
probably be with y'all more than likely
and then i might just head straight out
and then do after reactions with the
troubleshooter shout out to my my gang
and my squad man um that was just still
up in the air and i kind of i think i
canceled on everybody because i didn't
know what i was going to be here in that
but i i wrote with y'all first and then
i'm rock with them second and then we do
our thing but thank you whoever that was
in the chat thank you for asking i do
appreciate you know i appreciate the
fact that y'all
like me that much to be like where's
hustle damn i never thought i'd see this
day
well yeah obviously uh and then we got
we got dirt griggity man what's going on
dirt what is up man i you know i'm happy
to be back brother what's happening
that's two weeks in a row man thanks for
having me man i actually started your
prediction show uh last night i was
playing uh south park stick of truth and
i wanted something to listen to in the
background i was like oh dirt's
his prediction shows up because i'm in
my i'm on my prediction bag man i got
the little notepad like see who's going
right who's going wrong you know
you know obviously
one thing i will point out is kid smooth
and boom are not right
[Laughter]
[Music]
if they're right that would be the best
e3 well e3 i mean i need to stop with
this best e3 thing what that would be
the best xbox conference they that they
have ever done if they're right on that
matt smooth was even saying release
dates
oh wow
release dates he said like starfield's
gonna come out three three twenty three
oh wow
so it's it's gonna be epic man it's
gonna be epic so
we have
a lot of show for you guys today we're
going to talk about the xbox showcase
kind of give it like a last call it's
not going to be like a full prom
prediction like we did a couple weeks
ago uh you know hustle wasn't here on
that show so i want to give him uh the
opportunity to get his bars off when it
comes to that particular topic uh we got
some god of war might become getting
delayed a 2023 conversation uh hustle
did uh inform me before the show that
some people might be on twitter uh
but debunking that i haven't looked into
that yet but even if it got debunked we
still won't talk about it and then we
got the state of play review from last
thursday you know we we did give a
little bit of a predictions on what we
might or might not see on that so you
know we're going to talk about
how that's showing it out and then we're
going to talk about more games coming to
pc on the playstation brand because
that's my favorite topic oh man
let's talk about that first the yeah the
playstation games coming to pc please
tell me hustle because i know dirt saw
it please tell me her so you saw last of
us getting
leaked and it's coming to pc
yeah but i don't really think that's
much of a well i can't see what i'm
doing leak in quotations that's not
really much of a leak ever since um sony
or jim ryan announced the acquisition of
nexus
or next is how you pronounce it you know
they're the official pc porters i don't
know what you call them developers what
have you
when i saw like when we heard that
announcement and then we saw like some
type of paperwork involving uncharted 4
and lost legacy at some point this was a
little while ago when we saw i said oh
yeah it's it's not only is it coming we
just got to know when
um the first game we we saw during that
playstation event was a spider-man
because because a lot of people and i
know we'll
okay all right so i guess i'll i'll save
my thoughts on that as far as uncharted
being there oh wait where is that it was
last of us it was last of us well i said
uncharted i'm my fault for as far as the
last of us i saw something today on
twitter shout out to bg broken games hdl
y'all make sure y'all check out weapon
world each and every sunday at 5 45 p.m
um here tweeted out time bg 5 45 p.m hey
well you know yeah what it is
but i saw the um and i'm looking for the
tweet now if somebody had tweeted out
something extremely cryptic and it was a
date it was i think it was 2 9 22 which
would translate to september 2nd because
i think dude is from overseas so that
translates to september 2nd so no i'm
not surprised that we're seeing that um
my only
i guess
the question is what the hell is taking
them so long i mean you got the people
over there you supposed to you bring the
big dogs over here first nobody's going
to rebuy the last of us one um except as
as this remake i'm going to rebox that's
my second favorite game of all time but
like for real man throw that joint on pc
man and um it actually leads me to
believe that factions 2 is going to be
integrated with factions one i know
that's popular it was running around
anyway so i kind of when i see
when we see that announcement with that
room i added we're going to pc it's like
oh yeah that's probably factions too and
they'll probably make you pay 70 dollars
for it and everything too so
oh that's gonna be funny if they uh uh
supposedly the this remake is gonna like
have
uh certain of them
features
rebuilt from the ground up so i'm kind
of curious
uh if that's on their day and date on uh
what happens if they release that
version
on you know the rumored
remake
that that's the version that comes and
it comes their day and date when the
remaster comes out the remake comes out
now do you think that might be
us revisiting if they ever do a day and
day because i feel like if they do that
sure is that technically a remake from a
previous game yes
but we can't act like that's a little
bit that's like equivalent
to resident evil 4
being a
resident evil 4 being a exclusive to a
platform like nintendo microsoft and
playstation and this coming up one
is coming to pc dang date
so like i feel like look it's
technically an old game
but it's not an old game at the same
time because they're rebuilding it from
the ground up it's got new features it's
not the same game we played back in 2013
was when the last of us came out yep
2013. yeah so what do you feel about
that hustle you think that maybe maybe
we get a little closer to that day and
date conversation maybe we can have that
conversation more and more
i don't think so i think that this may
be an outlier for the simple fact that
they do want to release factions too and
if
again the factions too is integrated in
part one
like a lot of people are speculating
that it is then this i feel like this
don't count even though it's a remake
and it's rebuilt from the ground up i
get it i feel like this isn't like a new
title this is still the last of us they
would have to add in order for your
point i feel like for your point to be
like valid like an xbox thing the way
it's day and date in order for that to
be a valid type of thing
we would have to see a lot more in that
game we would have to see like cut teams
with ellie in it when you kill you know
how you how you all run through the game
and you'll see you'll you should be able
to like play from her perspective if you
if we see different stuff like that
that's
i understand your point but i feel like
that's that's stretching it just a
little bit that's just the mob me my
humble opinion i feel like that's a
straight that's that's a bit of a
stretch for me but it's addict i'm gonna
stretch stuff man call me mr mr
fantastic i'm stretching this arm all
the way to the other side of the ship
you know what ring richard you got it
but here's what i'll say though
i forgot his name i only know
i was watching that yesterday
i was actually about to say something
that probably would have spoiled
something i probably got upset was that
is that the person that i've never mind
won't go okay
well well no we don't gotta go there but
what i will say is is if we
take it if we were taking it there
it's not like uh
it's new but it's old do that make sense
like yeah they remade it but it's still
it's still old like a lot of that would
have a lot of stuff would have to change
a lot of things would have to be added
in order for this to be like a
day-and-date release w for like people
who care about that type of thing for me
oh my attic if it's so if if it is like
that and it's on pc day one you know i'm
getting it first right
ps5 for the take a road trip
oh man oh man i'm just saying i'm just
saying hey how you feel about that dirk
give a real cause you you like the last
of us too keep it real man i love the
last of us man i love the last of us um
so the question was added question was
will it
if it relaunches day and day um well
all right hold him get it right so the
question is do you think it will launch
day in day is that the question yes
okay
i think anything's possible my man
that's right because
anything's possible because you think
about the past
excuse me
i never thought playstation games would
be on pc to begin with
whether they're three four-year-old
games two-year-old games
they're on pc
so my point is things are changing um
it's obvious things are changing and i
believe if this game the last of us
remakes release on
pc day one
i believe i mean i won't be surprised i
believe it's definitely possible um the
way playstation is moving i don't know
why anybody would be surprised at this
point like you guys are talking about
nexus
we know for a fact nexus was acquired
because
they port console games to pc
that's their
it right and they do a great that's
their specialty
so when playstation big studios naughty
dog the sony cell democracy when they're
developing their games
they don't have to worry about porting
into pc that's why they have nexus so
i do believe it's possible obviously i
don't know if this is what's going to
happen but i won't be surprised if it
does release day one on pc as well as
ps5
i i do feel like there's a chance that
we might see this last of us come to uh
day and date with pc and ps5
now
do i think that that means like god of
war like a future in
installment comes day and day
i guess that's up in the air i obviously
ragnarok is
definitely coming to playstation 5 first
there's no denying that right i don't
think nothing is changed with that kind
of thought process but
with
if they are willing to let last of us
remake come out for the the pc first
that that's
that's what they do
then where does that leave the next god
of war the next
horizon like
i feel like if you're gonna let it do
one all it takes is one one little hole
in this in the armor
and then before you know it sony like yo
this last of us sold well on pc oh
exactly it's like okay you know what
what's the what can the next god of war
do you know maybe maybe worse we're
putting a game out too long
before it hits another platform and
everyone's been spoiled on the story
there's no more hype in the game
so yeah i think that might open up a
little bit of of doors but i don't think
it's gonna happen anytime soon i think
maybe by the end of the generation this
generation now you'll start seeing games
day and day like next four or five years
so
let's let let's
wha what's that thing called when people
say they go from uh one topic to another
transition
that's right segway
let's segue ourselves to to god of war
potentially being delayed to 20
23. uh keep in mind this is what a giant
thing is saw if i had saw it on me i i i
would i would pour it out but don't so
you're gonna have to just visualize it
supposedly
from leaked insiders or whatever it is
whoever these people are i don't know
we're just talking about it because it's
on twitter uh god of war might have been
pushed back to 2023. first thing i want
dirt is i want what was you doing when
you read this or what was your first
thought process
honestly
i was like okay i was looking at the
source i said okay this is not the first
time i saw was vg chart so i said okay
but they said rumor so it's not
confirmation yet it's not official
uh but so that was my first thought it
it's official it's just official you
know then i looked around and see sony
didn't say anything yeah so i said okay
it's not official yet um but
my second thought was very interesting
all right i mean this is
every game has been delayed right
the last three years pretty much i think
the only game that hasn't been delayed
was what forza horizon 5 maybe every
other game has been delayed you know
people want to say yo horizon and grand
tourism seven came out yeah those games
were originally 20 21 games and that's
the funny part just interrupt you real
quick dirt
last of us two was was delayed remember
at a point
this is the like the start of the
pandemic they delayed it indefinitely
until they figured out what they were
going to do with it right uh horizon's
been delayed return was delayed and you
can i i think return was delayed wasn't
it i'm pretty sure yeah
and you could arguably have a point that
maybe return and horizons should have
been dead like longer because they had a
lot of uh you know i wouldn't say a
little bit more on maternal than horizon
horizon had a lot of like annoying
glitches but it didn't have a whole lot
of like game breaking glitches but
maternal came out was broken just about
like it was constantly crashing systems
it was so bad that the developers
say it's the box
[Applause]
you know let me get this super chat real
quick we got a super chat from ko3
blacktruth
what's good fellas the hype is real xbox
showcase gonna be lit wbg on monday solo
podcast yesterday in the attic show
today
dot dot dot dirt every day
black truth what's up brother
yes i appreciate the uh uh the
generosity so look when it comes to it's
like look
people need to stop acting like stuff
like it's star filled red fall getting
delayed yeah it's only happening to xbox
like absolutely like the only reason
it's not happening to playstation
because they're not releasing any more
games right now no
like ratchet and clank was ratchet and
clank ever delayed
uh i don't know i don't think so maybe
that one wasn't delayed yeah maybe that
one wasn't not the grand trisman was
delayed
literally almost every game that sony
has put out in the past three years has
been delayed
oh yeah thank you for saying
apparently it was delayed it was at
russia yeah i don't think it was a big
delay but it was a delay yeah and as you
said hey you know what i'm glad you said
that because
that's the thing right those xbox guys
you know
we're waiting right unfortunately we
have a waiting game that we're playing
right now
but
the industry in general every game has
been delayed even multiplats
indies we just saw how the game uh
what's the game um
what's the indie game that looks amazing
and technically red fall didn't even get
a street date it just got a release
window
right and starfield only got delayed one
time because it's only got one release
date yeah so so this is what's going on
right now you know we all talk trash we
have fun you know when star feel the red
fought was delayed you know playstation
guys they they let us know about it and
you know it was it was kind of rough for
a few days but yeah guys
off twitter those couple days
it was rough even some xbox guys lost
their mind oh my god but
um
god of war listen i am a huge fan of the
game if it gets delayed will i talk
trash absolutely because you know that's
just the nature of the beast but
i understand it i mean every game is
getting delayed right now
so yes man i'll be okay with it and i do
think it's definitely possible i'm not
going to run with it until it's official
from playstation themselves um but yeah
man like i said it's no surprise and
this is the nature of the beast right
now every game is getting delayed yeah i
don't mean to interrupt y'all but um
replaced is that game that we replaced
thank you yes even indie games gets that
that's being delayed you know yeah shout
out to the chat for that yeah shout out
to the chat thank you guys we're playing
on consoles that should have been
delayed in general like i you know it's
just like well it's like
i don't know about that one at it
you talk about the the ps5 from the
series x and the series you know maybe
more on the ps5 than the series x maybe
a little bit more on that you know i
feel like the series that came out and
it was it was it was hitting the beat
correctly playstation 5 camera you heard
me hearing about overheating issues the
the uh the the rest mode was locking
people's consoles down return was
turning playstation 5's off
oh man
i bought i had rsc i had that game day
one and i i got that day one uh ps5 my
drawing being good and i don't put my
console in rest mode at all like yo i
don't know who does that like that i
just i never felt like do y'all put
y'all can do this you know what i'm like
no i complain
so you know what on my ps4 pro i used to
put it in rest mode um not with the ps5
i don't i just completely cut it off
well so i used to like i said with the
ps4 but now i just cut it off
i mean at the end of the day hustle how
do you feel about it do you feel like
you know
that when it comes to god award like you
know we were talking a little bit about
before the podcast you know spoiler
alert hustle still on the god of war
coming out this year which i hope he is
because this is kind of dry out there
man it's it's it's a desert out there
right now we need something we need we
need a niagara falls and i will say god
of war is
it it will definitely feed some people
man we all thirsty and that's some water
i feel like
according to what i saw today in terms
of like that rumored last of us thing if
last of us does drop in september then
god of war is dropping november now god
of war from what i understand doesn't
typically like the last one didn't drop
in november dropped in march but um
yeah no no we because we've seen a lot
of things in terms of promotion for on
twitter on social media right now before
y'all say well hustle that's social
media that's that's the new wave that is
the new commercial that is the new
everything everybody got their phone in
their head a lot of people on twitter
everybody watching the nba finals on
youtube tv
et
etc
and so on and so forth we've seen a lot
of things just in terms of promotion
like we saw something for national
accessibility day i saw something today
i was telling the addict in the dirt
about it today somebody was using like a
photo mode um we heard another
announcement about a photo mode in the
god of war or god of war one or 2018
whatever you would call it then we saw
like another rollout in terms of like
god of war the 2018 game it was already
on the ps5 plus collection but that was
just on ps5 plus all together now so
like
these things have been constant um even
with like when dude um who's sadly here
hurt his back i don't i don't know the
gentleman he plays he voices kratos
y'all know what i'm talking oh yeah a
christopher judge yes when that
gentleman heard his back even when he up
and tweeted that hey yo my fault the
game taking too long y'all um i hurt my
back or whatever and everybody was
responding to him what do you think that
was you know like that everything is a
roll out though everything is a rollout
and i'll tell y'all this i mean if it
was me and i was on like the marketing
team i mean you know because i kind of
feel like they need to put me there
because i would have the that game god
award in so many different areas and
arenas because we know the playstation
die hard is going to buy it but uh i'd
have to make the hip-hop heads by the
soccer moms by i'll be putting i will be
putting that promotion each and
everywhere let me kill whoever this is
in this chat yeah bro
hold on pop up everywhere yeah i do but
not now but but yeah that game is coming
out this year and i feel like it's
coming out november and if i'm
playstation hey look i know jason's
right jason if you're listening don't
don't don't take husband's word too
seriously but but if i'm it's only santa
monica
and we crunching dog because microsoft
don't got nothing at the top of the or
don't have nothing in the holidays like
they normally do yeah call of duty will
be there but people gonna buy who people
who buy call of duty will buy it anyway
i feel like they're gonna buy it anyway
i feel like this is playstation's like
opportunity to be like now here we go
and they can drop it a week after and
it'll be cool like now here we go we got
it and yeah i know god of war gonna do
10 15 mil dog so and it's on ps4 too
it's on ps4 and ps5 so y'all know what's
gonna do you know 10 15 possibly 20
million i might hit that last of us
number and yeah i mean like or less was
part one they might hit those numbers
but i definitely anticipate this game
coming out this year and
and if they don't then you know sony
they or herman holds whoever jim ryan
whoever
you know
yeah they need a foot up there behind
because just the opportunity like this
is the time you do it in my opinion
let me say this right quick i believe if
the last of us think is true for
september i believe call of duty i mean
i'm sorry god award definitely isn't
coming out this year
because they don't want to go even
though god of war is a monster over
franchise
still being in november
you know
or even october because kai comes out of
october this year
um i don't know maybe november is a
little open
you know but i don't i don't think i
don't know man i just don't think sony
usually doesn't release their games in
the holiday season oh
all i'm saying
is look could god war come out this year
yes and i actually really hope it does
like i might joke around but i've really
enjoyed god of war 2018. i'm a little
bit
i'm a little worried because it's not a
trilogy and i feel like there's a lot of
story that they could potentially tell
you know they're
they're it seems like they're focusing
the rivalry between kratos and thor in
this game and i'm just like what are
they going to do voting if there's not a
third game what are they going to do
with voting like am i fighting them both
at the same time like how are they going
to finish all that like i'm a little
worried how they're going to like
connect the dots with that but you know
if anyone could do it it's definitely
them it's just like i feel like
it's
we almost mid-june guys
and we
saw a release date we really saw too
much gameplay if you want to get
technical we've seen a little bit of
split splits when it comes to like uh
you know a little bit here then then
like a cut scene here a little bit here
than a cut scene here uh we haven't seen
anything full-blown and keep in mind
most the time right before they they
show a brand new game not a brand new
game but before they release the game
they they usually dedicate an entire
state of play to it
we haven't got that but they just did a
state of play not too long ago last
thursday we're about to talk about that
so it's like to me
when are they doing it
like because anyone that knows anything
about marketing marketing takes time
it's not something you do in a couple
days
so we're going to be we're about to be
in july which obviously this is a big
month they can easily
show it this month easily
it could be at the summer games tomorrow
tomorrow yeah
for all we know i personally feel like
that's not their mo
uh they've never really done something
like that now they might do it this year
but maybe because that's all they have
this year so you know they
they're not gonna do a whole showcase
for them but to me
they've never really gave something is
the caliber of god of war to someone
else
like they've never done that like to me
they're going to do that on their own
show maybe we'll see
some kind of story montage at the summer
game show and at the end of that they'll
say tune in on like the 18th or 19th for
a state of play revolved around god of
war
to me that's the only thing that makes
sense like no obviously
they might give
um jeff what's his name keely jeff
keeley that
the uh the privilege of showing
something like that uh but if you do
remember jeff keeley himself is kind of
keeping people's expectations low
like he's not telling you not to hype
his event up but he is kind of telling
you yo we have stuff we're revisiting
but
to me it seems like we got a bunch of
average games to good games that people
love we don't have anything that's going
to like blow everyone's socks off you
know what i'm saying
it like look like sure eldon ring was
shown last year and it's he kind of gave
the same vibe last year but eldon ring
is a third party game it's not
first party and if it was that xbox i'm
very confident xbox is going to show
something tomorrow
i don't know what it's going to be
but i'm pretty sure they're going to
show something tomorrow but that is not
sony's mo
and uh like i guess
you guys want me to me i just can't see
sony doing that i can't see sony taking
something as big as god of war probably
the biggest game they're gonna have for
a couple years
they just say
jeff keeley you want to show this
you know we could easily do a whole
state of play hike people up really good
by you want to do this i just can't see
that
i don't know um
there's a couple different things you
could think about in in 2018 i remember
playstation announcing it on twitter
god awards coming out whatever date it
was april march april they announced it
like a month before it if i remember
correctly they announced it you know
they had a trailer
said god awards coming this day and i i
do remember that um so maybe they might
do something like that again or or if
they announce it tomorrow
with a release date for this year okay
that'll be great but if they announce
something or have a gameplay trailer
tomorrow
and still no release date or
you know i think that's pretty strong
indication that it most likely won't
come out this year but i guess we'll see
you know is this our speculation right
now
so what what um
what do you have to feel hustle it do
you i know that you you're 100 on that
but
i just personally feel like
they're going to show it later on in the
year hustle
and then later on the year they're going
to be like oh
here's the release date it's gonna be in
2023. but they're gonna they're gonna
show a good presentation on steam play
they're gonna they're gonna captivate
people that's why i felt like they
should have did with star field show us
some good game play and in the name say
2023 because to me i'm still gonna i'm
gonna die on that hill just delaying a
game but you know what
no no
i'm sorry
i saw you finish your point
i'm just to me
delaying a game that we have not seen
nothing about
and not giving us any context to what
that game was and just randomly i feel
like that was a mistake
see now this now i disagree with you and
i'm explaining why i believe their
the way they did it makes better sense
i'ma tell you exactly why announcing
starfield has been delayed a month or
two before the showcase
it's good because if they would have
showed some great gameplay right after
they had already uh released their
etched in stone if they were to show
some great gameplay and then they ended
it with 2023
people would have disregarded the
gameplay example
september 2020 playstation had a great
showcase they had a great showcase i
remember watching that it's a pretty
damn good show
but at the end of the show
all people could talk about was how
horizon forbidden west was cross
generation they didn't even talk about
the show so in my opinion if xbox would
have showed some great starfield
gameplay
they would ignore the gameplay that's my
opinion
i get that and
i still understand where you guys are
coming from what's up one of those
scenarios where i understand it i might
not agree and i'm not even
disagreeing with you guys i could see
why they did that but i personally feel
like you go up there you show
great gameplay you hype people up and
then at the end of that you know sure
you're gonna get you're gonna get people
upset but you're gonna get people upset
regardless if you delay two months from
now a year from now the day before
you're gonna get people upset but at
least people would have seen yo
it got delayed but yo that looked good
that looked good like
uh yeah i mean i could see that but i i
don't think that would have been the
case because like i said sony had a
great show in september of 2020 and
nobody was talking about the show they
was talking about
hell yeah we believe in generations jim
ryan lied to y'all so even some
playstation guys are upset about it like
yo they you know
so i don't know i don't know well well
eddie i'll say this to answer your
question
if
they do show something that uh summer
games fast they almost called it the
killies if they do show something at
summer games fest it probably will be
like an announcement before an
announcement um it'll probably be like
hey
that you know like a recap of what we
already got when that state of play
happened with god of war it might be
something super quick to be like and
it'll be an announcement to be like hey
check out
such and such for god of war on because
we haven't heard a date for playstation
stuff have we
no there's no
uh there's i'm assuming there's a
showcase in like august i remember there
was a rumor it was supposed to be at
like the end of may the june you know
how these playstation insiders are they
i get more stuff right than they do but
it's just
i i i'm just
i want that show and that's where i feel
like they're going to show god of war
that's why i don't
buying on this we're going to show this
at at the summer games fast because
unless they're not going to have a show
this year so you need to tell like
like look if god of war shows up
tomorrow with a release date at the
summer gaming show i'ma come out here
and say playstation ain't showing up
this year because why would you give
your biggest playing card
especially if it comes out this year to
someone else when you have your own show
what you gonna end your show with
that's a great you know what that's a
great point if they you know what i
didn't think about that if they showed
that tomorrow
hmm does that mean playstation's not
having a show cause even with a game
like you said like god of war
they would even do a state of play to
show off that title because it's a huge
title that's a great point hmm yes like
tomorrow now tomorrow's going to be so
much more interesting thanks a lot eddie
let me get these super chats real quick
we got a 10 super draft from jd gamer
sony better delay god award they have
nothing for xbox onslaught in 2023 2023
will be the year of xbox or sony sitting
in a window saying maybe we shouldn't
have poked the dang bear
you know what jd games yeah jd you know
what i i think you're on to something
uh let me get this ten dollar super chat
down here we got a 10 a ten dollar super
chat from raven blade my boy ray blade
what's up man yeah raiden blade's uh
been part of the iop listeners for a
while man yeah man great guy great great
guy i believe that we will
that we will be seeing the replacement
for star field and red fall if i was in
studio were bought before the zenimax
stable so if only right the biggest
surprise would be rise 2 or killer
instinct versus mortal kombat now look
right
i'm gonna save i'm going to save the
super chat for the xbox but that's the
last call topic because
to tell you something
we're going to start that here in a
second all right so let's let let's move
off of this because all of you because i
feel like the xbox bethesda thing's
going to be the biggest thing we talk
about today let's move on to the state
of play
um any of you watch stay to play thing
did you watch it hustle i know dirk
watched it did you watch it hustle i did
i'm a little foggy on the memory so i
will look up a lot of that stuff but i
definitely caught it when it was live
last week
best day to play they've ever did best
thing to play they've ever done
i thought it was great
it's cool it was cool i i was in i was
entertained from the time it started to
the timing
that's the kind of pacing i want the
xbox show to have sunday
like that pacing was phenomenal now look
you can debate if you like the games
that was shown that's not pacing pacing
is how you show and what goes on and how
long they keep people talking if they do
game to game that's pacing pacing has
nothing to do with the taste of games
that they've shown
there's been years microsoft's had good
pacing i just didn't like the games
but that's the kind of pacing i would
appreciate microsoft to have
this state of play was fantastic it was
i agree a good show
that you know there's that sony's still
in this like i will say
it was good for for for xbox gamers too
i will say that
because
we saw stuff like street fighter is
finally out of the exclusivity
department it's going to be a
multi-fighting game which i think a lot
of people kind of figured i was a little
bit in the middle because i figured
sony
has evo
sony helped him so much with street
fighter v
i don't know when street fighter 6 was
originally in in play you know i know
street fighter 5 wasn't a huge
success for for capcom it was a good
success but i didn't know when they
dropped street fighter 5 and started on
six probably know they could have
started this game like three or four
years ago and sony already
mine looks
so it's nice to see because i i do
personally you know we'll get the hustle
here in a second but i personally feel
like
getting street fighter 6 back to the
xbox platform is huge i i agree
i agree so how do you feel hustle
this is how we're going to kick it man
yeah how what was the highlight thing
that you remember out of it that you
really enjoyed and
what did you think when street fighter
was when you found out because obviously
they're not going to say it on the state
of play yo we're coming to the
competition too they're going to put on
their ps4 and ps4 of course you know you
know what's funny people didn't even
know that
street fighter 6 was coming out for xbox
one
because if you look
if you look at the marketing for it it
says xbox series s and x yeah oh okay so
it is coming off of xbox one also yes
okay i didn't know that okay yeah i mean
fighting games what time is the summer
game show tomorrow
i think two o'clock in the eastern time
early yeah it's so early man
man yeah okay man i had to leave let's
take a half a day at work just to stream
it well i won't be able to see it at all
but let me uh before i answer that
question um
street fighter 6 i'll start there
because i don't want to forget um
it's cool that you know street fighter
is coming back to
coming back to multi-platform well
coming back let's xbox i want to see
everybody who was excited for you i got
to play that you know i tried street
fighter 5 i just wasn't feeling it too
much the gentleman
in the very beginning i don't know what
his name is i'm not sure i'm not the
fighting game cat but it's giving me
street fighter 3 vibes and let me
explain to y'all what i mean all right
so when street fighter 3 first came out
dirk i think you're a little bit older
than me but you remember when it first
came in the arcade
and a lot of people were trying to they
were trying to get capcom was trying to
get away from ryu and ken so a lot of
those characters you saw oh yeah yeah
yeah so a lot of those characters you
saw in the beginning like you saw a big
uh key component on alex at that point
alex yep it didn't really work and this
is these are the vibes that i'm getting
again now so with the street fighter 6
thing in particular i saw it look like
it looked like a
nba 2k like my park or whatever that is
that's what it kind of reminded me of
i'm like well they tried to make it open
world but i said i wonder if it's just
like a dragon ball fighters thing though
you just run around looking for people
to go fight
i don't know the story mode or something
you know their story mode yeah
so i don't i don't know if that's gonna
be fully fleshed out also i i doubt i
thought very seriously that capcom makes
the same mistakes that they did with
street fighter v let me explain what i
mean by that
i did and i still got street fighter 5
sitting around here somewhere
i play like the four matches it's like
it's a story mode there's only like four
matches it's not even like i wouldn't
even count that as like a story mode um
it was just like four quick little
fights and they had like text at the
bottom
but i guess before they oh like this was
must have been beforehand but where they
had like a dedicated story mode the one
that you'll see on the internet and all
that so i kind of feel like they're
going to correct that i don't think
they're going to have those quick little
mini fights anymore um
i just want to say this um we had uh saw
some i'll say friends of the show or
friend of the show right paris he had
made a comment you know about uh
you know who wants killing anything hey
listen i'll tell you this i want killer
instinct and i'll tell you why if street
fighter 6 hit like street fighter 5 in
the very beginning with terrible online
and you know and it just don't hit the
same
then we all we always need that
competition and street fighter um killer
instinct is different from from a street
fighter it's different from mortal
kombat it's different from a blaze blue
is different from a dragon ball fighters
and this is why we kind of need that
variety in the fighting game genre it's
different all that stuff is different
from tekken and this is why i enjoy the
fighting game space a lot too because
you can you got a wide variety of stuff
that you can always play and i know i'm
going on top of it but i don't mean to
but you got a variety of stuff that you
can always play and everything is a
little bit different and everything has
it has its own place um
i hope i answered your question there
but oh wait the game that i um did that
kind of shocked me a little bit aside
from my marvel spider-man going to pc
and i guess we're going to talk about
that at some point it's a game called
roller dome i don't know if y'all saw it
but it's like yeah
yeah that's all
i think it's going to be available
everywhere but that's that's dope um
that that to me was like super dull i
love the audience
like that yep
i'm gonna take a crack at it i won't
take crack at that
yeah
i i do feel like you know dirt you know
clearly i i saw you post about it man
you know we'll bring up a little bit but
the spider-man you know i i i want to go
through both of you two real quick after
we uh we talk about uh dirt's highlight
uh you know dirt
once again same question that asked
hustle you know what was the highlight
of the show to you and what was your
thought process when you saw that street
fighter
yo first off i agree with what you said
this is the best state of play they ever
had
um it was a game that had some
some great multiplayers like like first
off
remember when you guys asked me what's
my most anticipated game this year and i
said callisto pro uh protocol and you
guys like yeah okay
boom that looked great looked absolutely
amazing i can't wait for that game um
resident evil 4. you know resident
before i never actually finished that
game back in the day
so to see that the remake is going to be
a thing i can't wait for it because i
finished i recently well not recently
but i finished the remake of part two
and part three because i didn't finish
them back in the day so i'm really
looking forward to that um you know all
i look at
i like almost every game now the vr
games eh you know not really my thing
but
you know i know they had to show what
they had to show but back to your point
of street fighter 6 i think is huge
because
a lot of xbox folks last generation when
si which street fighter 5 was announced
to be playstation 4 exclusive a lot of
people's upset
ip was upset about it and to see that is
coming back to xbox and it's
multi-platform
i think it's a great that's great and it
looks pretty good to me it looks pretty
good i'm not a huge street fighter guy
like growing up street fighter was the
stuff in the early 90s when i like my
teenage years
then mortal kombat just kind of grabbed
me and i didn't look at street fighter
the same way ever again right but uh
street fighter is a solid game i can't
wait to uh play i'm definitely going to
buy it this time but yeah i thought the
show was um damn good
i thought it's like i said
great pacing you know that that was by
far that was like a nintendo direct
pacing and most of the time nintendo
direct don't got nothing i want like
they got like one or two games there but
i felt like they had a very appealing
catalog at that state of play you know
some things might not agree to you some
things uh might uh but i feel like that
state of play gave something a little
bit to everybody agree absolutely i
wholeheartedly agree with you
let me get let me get this ten dollar
shot from jd gamer speaking of evo
remember back when sony had first bunny
halted sf uh street fighter 5 evo still
had street fighter 4 and they had to use
the 360 version at the event because the
ps3 version sucks capcom remembers that
uh to be honest with you i get what
you're saying jd i do i get what you're
saying bounty capcom cares they care
about where that money is and if that's
it if sony
it's like this
this incident thing going on like the
johnny depp thing you know he said in
live court i ain't never gonna work for
disney again but now it's rumored that
you know he might go back to disney
because supposedly they offered him like
three four hundred million dollars it's
like an apology to come back like you
know money talks brother
i was gonna say you know how much money
they had to offer that man in order for
him to come back like that like you
that's oh he about to cash out shout out
to well you know on that violin we won't
talk about that stuff here
you saw that whole thing though
yeah he he
i have a feeling that
you know not to get off the subject too
much that disney
knew that if they if they want to do
anything with the pirates of the
caribbean franchise
they had to make that right or they'll
never be able to and
because at this point i feel like his
fans aren't going to watch it and his
fans is the pirates of the caribbean
absolutely man he is jack sparrow bro
you can't put tom cruise in there to be
no he's jack sparrow right was that was
that rumor they were trying to get no no
i'm just you know i'm just saying some
random dude no yeah
yeah so it's like i said jd at the end
of the day
as long as sony made that right capcom
ankle don't care they're like
you know we oh you
we mad man you and first off whose fault
is that really is that sony's fault is
that capcom's fault they made the port
for the playstation um right
if i remember right now i do want y'all
to correct me with somebody trying to
correct me i thought sony funded that
game
street fighter 5 yeah you know what i
think that might be true because we was
actually talking about this on my show
the other day
capcom didn't have a great
uh 360 ps3 generation not at all
they were struggling at that time and
i'm pretty sure i think i also read that
hustle that playstation um funded street
fighter 5. okay so
there's definition credence to that
because i i remember doing research on
it but no no capcom at that point they
was down bad yeah they sound bad man
yeah it was it was it was dying over
there and it was
so so so much in fact that a lot of
people wanted microsoft to bomb but you
know yeah say unless i guess but it was
just one of those things um
i'm looking forward to you know i hope
it has cross play
on that level and i hope it's cross play
everywhere it's a fighting game you
shouldn't
it shouldn't be
look it should just be cross-play that's
all i'm saying should be should we cross
play everywhere so i'm looking forward
to that i'm looking forward
i personally feel like
we've gotten to a point the moment call
of duty went cross-play everything needs
to be cross-play i don't want to hear
especially the bare minimum we should be
handling is prospect cross-progression
like there should be no
we we need to be very strict on that
like look if your gaming cross play we
ain't messing with it because it's just
like you know
unless they have reasons like small
indie developers i know indie developers
doing crossfit between pc and uh steam
and vr so there's no excuse really you
know what i'm saying like but i there is
extreme circumstances so i'm not going
to say like you know everyone has to do
cross play but i feel like especially if
you're a third party and you got
millions of dollars at your budget if
you don't got a cross play there there's
no reason for it none whatsoever
all right so
let's let's let's get it man let's get
it the xbox and bethesda show okay okay
wait a minute there's one more thing i
want to mention there's one more thing i
feel like we got to mention it yeah
spider-man coming to pc uh to nobody's
surprise
to absolutely no one's surprise
look okay look look okay we can talk
about it you know i was trying to be a
little bit less spicy you know i was
trying to add a little bit less
spiciness to the
so so hold up hold up we're going to
start we're going to start with dirt
dirt yeah
now
before the show
there was leaked images showing where
turner coming to pc
so i think we can all assume that when
that said a fan favorite first off
return you know fan favorite so i think
you can throw that out right there right
but second off when you saw that
we're bringing a game to pc dirt is that
what you originally thought was gonna be
no
no
no no no oh so you automatically thought
it was going to be spiderman no no i
didn't know what it was going to be
until i saw that insomnia logo then i
was like
what is this
then the nexus logo gave it away i was
old nexus oh damn spiderman covers the
pc oh my god that nix's logo gave it
away because like it sounded like you
know like he wasn't sure is it gonna be
spiderman
yeah probably uh they're not gonna do
sunset overdrive right
bro
that would have been mad actually i
think that would have been funny if it
would have been since that overdrive the
pcc
like a remaster coming to pc
you know what's not playstation it's
already on pc and now i think about it
no i'm talking about a remaster oh yeah
yeah that would be funny yeah so uh
so when we saw that now of course
on like my boy sean 786 uh channel we
were just talking trash because let's be
honest you know playstation guys there
was you know attic you've been around
for years
you know all of the narratives you know
everything those guys said playstation
would never
put their games on pc then it changed
into well they would never put
spider-man on pc that's their biggest
franchise and here well first it was god
of war
to spider-man you know what's funny
i've been around since 2014 okay right
i've been around these youtube streets
you know periodically making content i
didn't really take my personal youtube
channel seriously we didn't make the
iron loss podcast to like i think 2016
or 17. i don't know that's besides the
fact
i've seen
resolution gate i've seen
i've seen
i've seen everything man
and what's funny is when you're seeing
these playstation people
i saw the xbox people did it the same
way when that was starting to happen
when the quantum break went to uh as a
as a
what was that what was that
on pc yeah what was that program called
originally they had a program
that it was like what was the name of it
hold on wait um
damn it it was a name i can't think of
the name right yeah but quantum break
was the first game they did it with yeah
i seen it all i seen play anyway that's
what it was playing anywhere yeah i've
seen it all i seen
you know i i there's a there's a podcast
where i'm on a podcast with kofi and i'm
saying look
um
this does devalue the xbox brand just
like it devalues the playstation brad
but look
it
there is a matter of how much and i
think people get that mixed up does
games coming from playstation to pc
devalue the playstation brand yes
but to what degree it's only really
devaluing people that have pcs
and sure
i'm willing to bet you there's a lot of
people that have pcs but i've always i
got this this i got hit one time because
i said this i don't think anyone that
goes out there and builds a pc and has a
pc for gaming
they're not casual sure there's some
people that they play casual games
because they want a pc but if you're
going out spending thousands of dollars
or even a like six seven hundred dollars
you're not a casual gamer right there's
not a lot of them out there sure there's
there's millions of them but when you're
talking about the demographic of people
that's a very small percentage
and then people aren't going to get a
ps5
but when you look at how many a game
sells on playstation 5 like god of war
20 30 million sure it's a little fluff
it's a little fluffed but we ain't going
to talk about that you know 20 30
million it might be more i don't know so
20 30 million how much did it sell on on
pc not even a million didn't it it still
hadn't been over a million so no clearly
there's there's a demographic there
because when a pc person gets a pc
nine times out of ten they got it for a
specific game and they playing that
specific game
yeah i mean yeah i
understand what you're saying but i'm
glad you mentioned all those other
things because you i'm glad to be able
to talk to a guy that's been around i
was just one of the guys in the chat
back in 20 you know 14. i always talk
about this on my channel but uh yeah so
to see spider-man be a novel piece it
it was funny to me
it was a little funny i got to be honest
it was funny uh we we just had the ball
we were laughing we were making fun but
it makes sense
it makes sense jim ryan himself said uh
you know the 10 to 20 million
cops well not like copies of their
biggest first party games so this is
just not enough anymore
and you see you know like they were
announced today uh sony man they're
doing a
multi i mean uh game with multiplayer
i'm not a changer obviously we've
completely
went off the rails i first saw people
cooking me in the chat real quick let me
address
some of these people in the chat let me
move my mic man
i want to i want to address some of the
people in the chat saying addict but
that look
okay okay i'm trying to find out how i'm
gonna address this okay
dirt
let's say 10 people
when spider-man wasn't going to be an
exclusive
let's say 10 people was going to buy a
ps5 but they got pcs so they're like you
know what i don't need to buy a ps5
right
if they don't buy 10 ps5s
that means there's 10 less ps5 is being
sold does that not devalue the console
brand
i guess if you want to say that yeah so
to me people said they're all attic
they're different honestly it's a
different audience but they play the
same games
like you guys acting like i didn't say
it's a huge portion i didn't it's
literally a small portion of people that
they're not selling but they're selling
probably 10 million more potential
people that they can sell games to it's
not devaluing the brands devaluing the
console and that's okay because at the
end of the day if you have access to
play that game why does it matter where
you're playing that game
but
but to say the mo all it takes is one
person
kofi kofi wouldn't buy a console bg you
know obviously they bought it but they
don't need those consoles for those
platforms and the moment they don't need
it that devalues it
it's not a huge portion like i said but
people need to stop acting like putting
pc games on on on pc putting console
games on pc doesn't devalue that it does
it's just
the pc crowd is a very unique
crowd and it's hard to sell a game to
them they got a lot of stuff they got to
go through and i'm not saying that it
devalues you to where no one here should
buy a pc i'm not saying that at all
if you have it
you need to do it but the moment you
don't need something because it's
somewhere else it's devaluing it why do
you think they went from selling
exclusives to console exclusives i'll
wait for the chat
why do you think they need to re
redefine the term
because they can no longer use the word
exclusive they'd use consoles that's
fine because they're going to make more
money in the long run because they're
going to sell more eventually
continue
okay okay well i'll just say this um
as we were you know just as i was just
sitting back listening
you said you know you didn't want to
derail a podcast but i got i got to read
a little bit uh
question for you uh what's my most
anticipated game this year you know the
answer to this one sir
um
uncharted no no no no no my most
anticipated game this year you should
know
i keep oh teenage mutant ninja turtle
yes
so teenage mutant ninja turtles via a
tweet from limited run games um don't
cut shredder no slack
shredders revenge classic edition will
include
stuff that i'm not going to read so
the other day when we saw like the state
of play i thought we would get an
announcement for um shredder's revenge
right and but i think we're getting that
jeff kelly show if we're going to be
honest anyway i say all of that to say
this limited run games has announced
different um editions and they had a
live stream on monday that was brought
to you via game spot you don't want to
mess them up you know the publication
like ign they had a a whole limited run
live stream and they had this thing the
way they showed off shredders revenge
i'm thinking we get a release date there
no they didn't give us a release date
but they they told you some things that
were going to be in the collector's
package you actually get a coupon from
um what's that you actually get a coupon
from my pizza hut
i say all i have to say this again not
only did we not get a date there but we
didn't get a date today either so
they're selling everything but they're
not giving us a date i'm gonna need the
limited run games i'm gonna need that
emu i'm sure they're listening i'm gonna
trip you games nickelodeon give me what
i want
stop playing with me though stop this
rollout is entirely too long you just
said the summer games first start
tomorrow
whoever's streaming this when y'all see
shredders revenge they were like hustle
wanted to see this because i'm not going
to be able to see it now i had to go off
on my little ramp because i really want
to play the game you know like it's
taking too long like what's going the
jordan was looking ready then attic you
played in their packs
yeah it was awful i don't think i
technically played it i saw people play
it um okay so king and then play it's
not for me man i i told them because
they're supposed to gonna send us i
guess they're gonna send us review codes
or something i said i'd give mine to you
because i don't want to play it
well i can appreciate that but but still
still like i see that and it was just
like it was as y'all was talking i'm
glad i wasn't on camera because my the
way my face just dropped dog i felt
you ever feel like deflated and angry
but this he just was like oh yeah come
on we don't we don't care just come on
like it was just one of those things um
oh and i say i like to say this and it
brings us back to the state of place
stuff too i actually thought they were
gonna announce to that state of play
i'll keep in trouble with you i thought
they were gonna either announce that
state of play or i thought they were
going to announce the uh konami
collection but they understood one of
those things and i was disappointed
again i'm getting a whole lot of
disappointment from from what's going on
here i guess this is what i'm trying to
say um
yeah you know playstation's at the
center of all your disappointment
well
not no no no no i got i got i got all
the playstations in two different
consoles i got ps3 and i got ps5 i'm
joking i'm joking don't do that to me
i want the game to come out and i got
people who i interact with on twitter
like i got a homeboy of mine shout out
to my boy mega he was like yo
he got a source that said it'll be uh
it'll in my shadow drop tomorrow i say
probably now but i keep hope alive i'm
gonna keep hope alive
all right so let's go ahead let me get
the super chat real quick in this member
chat so we got a five dollar superchat
from jd gamer did you see
did you all see the reports that uh
sandra arriva uh buying embrace your
group at or at least starting to
with 1 billion initial investments so no
microsoft buying them i didn't think
that microsoft was going to buy that
company anyway like
microsoft doesn't need that many
microsoft having a hard time
managing the students they have i'm not
i'm not trying to add like 50 no it's
like they have like a couple hundred
don't they yeah ridiculous some crazy
amount yeah
now i wouldn't mind if they went to them
like yo what you guys using that uh uh
that that ip for let me borrow that let
me borrow that i wouldn't mind they
bought some ips from them if you think
about it they are an ip heaven like they
got like all the double a games that
could go trip life it was properly
funded like they got a lot of them but i
don't know if they're ever gonna like
properly fund some of these games then
we got a member uh we uh uh [ __ ] j with
the with the member chat been a member
for 11 months
spider-man
uh spider-man pc is gonna have some of
ray tracing tech used on dirt's head in
it oh come on come on come on jacob show
some respect
he was funny
i was reading
i didn't respect and what's funny is i
don't normally like
i was reading as i was doing it when i
got to the end i was like oh maybe i
shouldn't have read that like no i'm
sorry man this you know like jk now you
know like he'd be rocking out with us on
wbt
they be roasting my uh
head and they roast my complexion they
always talk about dark i am you know
it's this is crazy man
but it's all good right y'all got it all
right so
here we go guys
it's the xbox and bethesda last call
like i said okay
addict
i did this
with
i think it was addict me clearly it was
dirt
dark uh uh
um
what table was there i think bunny forte
and um
shinny party shiny was there so that was
the people hustle wasn't here so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna
i'm gonna go over a couple of the things
that we want over there i'm not going to
do the whole thing it's too long we
ain't doing that all right
i've got about 45 minutes on this topic
uh but first thing we're going to do is
hustle
what is
how do you feel about xbox right now
going into this event
it's looking bad for tim green over
there let me tell you oh looking bad
looking looking bad i mean you had two
at well one and a half anticipated
titles coming out this year yeah look
can we talk about that for a brief
second why do people keep breeding red
fall and they're acting like people is
looking for red fall like i'm not saying
that game didn't have any hype in it and
had no right being hyped but we can all
agree no one knew anything about that
game sure nobody knows anything about
star field but we know what kind of game
star field is for the most part i didn't
know what kind of game red fall was i
knew i could play with three other
people that's about all and every time
people would sit there and you know how
many
videos i watched where people was like
oh you know since highly anticipated red
fall and starfire i'm like i never heard
one person say they wanted to play that
game yet we hadn't seen enough
but continue hustle that's cap boy it
might care about no reform for real for
no but since uh red fall and um more
importantly uh starfield it got delayed
it it's looking it's looking bad man i
mean you know etiquette hit me up a
couple days ago and you had asked me
like what i really wanted to see from
xbox
all right i'm gonna start with this wall
i'm definitely going to start with with
the gears award like remake uh it
probably won't be out this year i
thought that very seriously however i
would like to see an announcement being
made because
just to clarify
i would bring your expectations back
down when it comes to that
gears i i would bring that down no i
didn't say it was gonna come out this
year and i
uh no
about it existing okay
okay okay um
i see the message people say it's
because red falls down i guess that i
guess maybe because i'm a huge fan of
that type of star filled stuff
but i can understand thinking about it
even though i didn't know a whole lot
about it i think maybe it's just i i'm
exhausted
exhausted on the co-op stuff i feel like
everybody's wanting to do the co-op
stuff right now so maybe that has
something to do with it we don't know
enough information for me to have like a
real opinion on the matter uh but i can
understand now continue continue
yeah so
you know with that i feel like they're
going to have to show
a lot now i mentioned giz but uh also in
the video that i submitted to uh
ironwood and if you guys haven't seen
that uh episode of the airlords podcast
you make sure you go check that out uh
perfect dark for me you know and i do
want to add something to that but i want
to see more with perfect dark and um
like i said they got the time to show it
now and actually some more information
has come out since then since uh our
people on sunday attic you know and dirt
they have um they have another extended
showcase that's coming up like on like a
tuesday or something like that yeah yeah
so i'm like all right so they got a lot
so here's kind of what i want right i
want to see gold in there um it's
heavily it's damn they all confirmed at
this point with all the like leaks and
rumors that we're seeing in terms of
gold now
it'll probably be a multiplayer but i do
want to see that on the xbox stage
because yeah as a person who has gold
907 i'm looking right at it right now
right in front of me
those controls have aged absolutely
abysmally i don't know if that's a word
but we're gonna rock with that today
those controls are horrible i tried
playing it y'all know i'm a retro cat i
tried playing it it's just not gonna
work so i want that to be like like a
shadow drop
you don't really need no promotion for
gold now everybody who won't buy that
gonna buy that and i'm gonna be one of
the ones you're gonna go about it um
if we don't see that summer game
showcase them all shredders revenge
i'm gonna keep drilling that point home
um
and one of the things that probably
nobody has hasn't mentioned probably in
this community except me right um aew
fight forever um that game is actually
rumored to release this year i say that
they said that they feel like they need
to show it on the xbox stage even though
it's gonna be a multiplayer i feel like
if they show it on the xbox stage a lot
of people who are wrestling fans will
probably be like oh okay it's not wwe or
wwf 2k or whatever this is something
game ain't looking too good man you tell
them screenshots yeah yeah i saw them
animations are super stiff i hope they
delay it i hope they personally delay it
but i got my thoughts on that um but if
it is scheduled to come out this year
you know show that on the xbox stage um
let's see is i would say show a new ip
like indiana jones is the one that
really like sticks out in my mind i love
uncharted so much
indiana jones would be something that i
would want to see this year and even
though that's a little ways away um
somebody had mentioned acquisition talk
i don't think they announced any more
acquisitions
um what the hell was the name
uh
the people who who who don't people who
made uh we happy few
composition compulsions yes i said it
first yes and i appreciate it i
appreciate the both of you i think we
see compulsions new project it'll
probably be like a splash screen or
something but
uh i i have heard phil spencer talk
awfully big about like yo yo i can't
wait till y'all see compulsions new
joint they're making it seem like it's
like their last of us or something so
hey i love that i love the game in
particular so we'll see we'll see if um
if there's more to to that in terms of
what compulsions doing i want to see
that uh hellblade 2 i'm sure they'll
show if they got two shows back to back
like that
then i'm sure they're going to show a
whole lot i see over 430 people in the
chat right now can y'all please hit the
like button and share it out tell a
friend to tell a friend that we are back
once again and yes i stole that from big
bear business but that's not the point
thank you all for joining us so let me
get back to what i'm getting at
if we are going to show new stuff
grounded i know have y'all played y'all
played grounded before right i played
grounds
recently uh i had my girl download it
because i figured that'd be a good game
for us to play
because she she is
she she's been a gamer in the past but
she's never like really played for long
amounts of time
so i'm trying to like get her like
really comfortable with the controller
you know what i'm saying so
uh
it's it's kind of crazy how
good ground it looks
like really
it i haven't played it in a long time it
looks good it looked good when it came
out like like
yeah i guess i mean i'm talking about
like the the lighting in that game the
like it's
it's crazy now i don't know
i don't know what kind of game it is now
because i haven't played it in so long
right but i had her download it because
obviously it's in game pass uh so you
know it's easy uh
even with people in general it's easy
for me to hit up cog yo download this
let's try this out
because it's on game pass everyone has
access to it so i think i might actually
try to stream that uh every now and then
to see how that game goes i remember you
know my recipes that dizzy dizzy used to
be like really big into that game he
loved that game uh and i feel like you
know
games like that now obviously bleeding
edge uh that was sad because i i felt
like that game could have went further
than it did i agree but it's it's it's
interesting we're gonna go but you know
hustle just just to roll it back a
little bit yeah you know that's what is
let's let's stay away from what you
think's gonna be there what i want is uh
besides gears
what do you want to be at this event for
you to come out at the other end of this
tunnel that we know is the xbox bethesda
train feeling
good that you got everything you need uh
because right now you don't even i don't
think you own an xbox right now do you
no yeah no yeah yeah so
yeah so right now what what what is
something they'd have to do
where hustle you look at that screen and
you're like damn i gotta go buy an xbox
like what's something that they would
have to do at this event to get you on
that train
huh
i mean because it well it's hard for me
to say that i i get i get why you're
asking that question but all the stuff
on pc i'll say this i'll say this uh
a new banjo kazooie because i was gonna
say because we were talking about what i
wanted to see on um from xbox i wanted
to see rare replay come to a game pass
on pc but since i'm thinking about a
rare replay i like to see like a banjo
kazoo a new banjo kazooie or like a new
like viva pinata come to the new xbox in
order for me to like try that out
uh killer snake like a killer because we
you know
they don't think i'm taking shots i'm
not taking shots to nobody but uh if
they announce some type of killer
instinct
you know how they set it up and it's not
free to play it's not this it's not
formatted the same way it was before
um because as y'all know i've been on my
fighting game kick so
if they announced like a new killer
instinct
cool then i'll copy a couple series s or
series x for that i would i would
definitely buy it for that
um
well microsoft i mean xbox they're a
little a little too big to have like a
beat em up there because i love beat em
ups and stuff like that too
they're a little bit too too big for
that i don't think that they have uh
they may not have a deal but like the
people who made like river city girls or
something like that they may not have a
t type deal like that so i wouldn't say
anything in terms of beat em ups but um
i don't know like i would like to see i
would like to see a banjo kazooie there
because i used to play that as a kid
what's up if they release banjo i'll be
extremely happy you have no idea what's
funny is that cat for banjo and i've
never beat banjo but they can't continue
you ain't get all the jiggy pieces at it
come on man i think what it is is like
you know my dad got me into gaming and
that was like my dad's favorite game so
like it kind of like gravitated towards
me when i grew up
oh i got you that's that's the style
just that's called nostalgia i go
through it as a retro game all the time
i don't know how you feel about that but
that's a hell of a drug boy i love love
the old stuff man i have nostalgia too
you know i watch old movies watch old
youtube clips play old video games
that's why i'm actually gonna stop stop
the presses start the presses yeah shout
out to the finalists and he got this
article from wccftech.com
fable and perfect doc won't be featured
at xbox showcases says friend of the
show jeff grubb
well yeah we kind of knew that yeah
i didn't know that i didn't know about
the family so much but i was looking
forward to perfect y'all had me saying
perfect y'all look crazy out here in
these streets
that
i couldn't hold away i could have told
you
throw the show away because perfect dart
and fable ain't gonna be there no no not
because of fable no no because perfect
dark won't be they throw the show away
throw hustle no bruh well no
no
no no no
nah
oh man that sucks if that's true that
that sucks man that's it's okay man they
got enough content we'll see you next
year we got enough content in
development yeah i know but that's
that's not the point like yo perfect doc
was another one i grew up on like
playing is that and you know
the co-op would have been there like you
know playing as joanna playing this
elvis but i don't wanna i don't want to
get too too far off topic but addict um
as far as that goes i wanna see um like
another viva pinata like yeah i remember
how it was back in the 360 when they had
all these titles from ray and all that i
want to see that type of movement over
there in order for me to get it
compulsions new game too like composer's
new game especially though like because
the first fence is going on about it and
it's like
it's something like the last of us even
if it's quote unquote the last of us
like part one
you know hustle be there for that man
i'm there for that one so let me get
this right
um perfect doc is not going to be there
throw the whole show away but but you
want a viva pinata no he had asked me
before he asked me beforehand i was
answering the question when i saw this
this earth shattering news here
it made me stop i'm not gonna lie make
me stop it made me stop in my tracks
dawg like that's perfect dog
that's i think i think the thing with
perfect art let me get these super chats
real quick uh i'm one of the original
uh we got a a 18 a a member chat from
raiden blade it's been a member for 16
months
i'm one of the original
rt dirk
creators what is rt
ray tracy maybe i don't know ray tracing
dirt creators especially on iop
anyway about and compulsion should be
the game's drop before any cinematic
studio game
i think he's referring to maybe because
they've been bought by so long i don't
know we got to find out if jeff when
we're stirred by life can we get halo
out of the hands of 343 uh via petition
or is it just microsoft's problem uh we
ain't gonna really go too much on that
we talked about microsoft i mean three
four three plenty on here uh i feel like
we do got to give them a little bit of
time to correct that uh but you know
here's the thing
people keep saying this companies to
take that company needs to take halo the
only company that is alive right now
that's in existence that can handle halo
for every aspect halo has is 343
maybe they need restructuring forms i
don't know but
i don't think people say i it by acting
like okay did you play the multiplayer
to any doom game no what
what's like how you gonna ask a studio
that that's never made a game like halo
to make game they act like the only
thing that's missing on halo is the
story no it's not right uh then we got a
17 we got a member from hustle and
motivate been a member for 17 months
throw the whole show away shake might
hit that like button please please uh we
ain't throwing the show away man
no sir not at all
look
at the other day when it comes to that
like
perfect dart
they got a lot of issues going on
i don't know if it's going to contribute
to what's going on directly they got to
fix those and i and i do feel like
we don't need to see perfect dark
i agree i don't think we need to see at
this point
god i hate y'all
hustle's a cornball you want to get
blocked in here hatred don't play with
me like that oh [ __ ]
see the thing is i've been all type of
time too homie don't play with me like
that
there was
a time with the xbox one generation
where they had to show every single
thing they had in development which
wasn't much the second half for last
generation
so when you think about the game like
perfect dark yes we want to see the game
but if that game is a little further out
like the same thing with fable if those
games are 20 24 okay
we'll see them next year um i want them
to show some games that's closer uh you
know some
2023 titles or you know or even some
2024 titles but the fable and perfect
dark are further away no need to rush it
you know like we want to see something
to see them next year
you know that's how it goes you have
this much content in development i just
think you know you have the luxury of
kind of picking and choosing you know
like i said xbox didn't always have that
luxury of having enough content to pick
and choose what to show at their show so
and to be honest with you they're
screwed no matter what they do
if they did show these games uh you know
i think they might
pull a card and show a game that's a
couple years away to try to make up for
the starfield lack that's at the show
maybe end it with like a fall at new
vegas too because i know that there was
conversations to have that game yeah uh
but it's just like at the end of the day
you know we'll definitely get to uh
hustle exactly you know
ex what kind of like mic drop moments
they they need to show gameplay and i
think that's what we want more i don't
want to see a lot of more announcers
sure i want to see some
i want to see new stuff and i think
they're going to show us new stuff but
they have announced so much stuff in the
past couple years yeah i want to see
stuff on that at this point
i don't i agree with you wholeheartedly
i don't want you to
open up six more doors when there's 18
that's already open hey i like we have
too many doors that's open let's close
some of them before we continue on where
we're going now no i'm not an analogy
alec
as far as like there's an extending one
uh there's an exten there's a second
showcase that's in like the 12th or
something uh knowing that that's there
i'm kind of i'm kind of curious if like
forza horizon even shows up at this
you know they might show that expansion
there so it's curious on that but you
know hustle real quick
i want to hear your mic drop moment
something that when you saw
you would you would act like kids move
when they bought all those studios in
2018
well well it would have would have been
perfect doc but you know i don't want to
be i don't want to beat that dead horse
um
damn
you know having a hellblade 2 uh
announcement or have a release date for
hellblade 2 um to kind of like go back
over what you guys just said like you
know you said just so many doors open
like let's start to get like release
dates
for the stuff that's been in early
development when they bought all these
studios in 2018
um
but i figured the biggest mic drop
moment though and i don't know if they
can announce it but if they if you know
activision deal goes through if that
deal goes through they announce that
deal like they'll be like hey we just
want to let you all know that you know
this is the best place to play whatever
you know they do
it would be crazy
it would be crazy
if they if it's
if it's done and they were able to go
out there and say we're putting all
bethesda inactive
all those games into
[Music]
into game pass day and date now like
they they like imagine like the
background lights up with all the call
of duty's but the new one and it says
they all in game pass right now
like it it would hit different you know
in overwatch
that goes in game password diablo 4
shows up and it's in game pass date this
year like it's it's going to be a big
thing man it's going to be a big thing
and i honestly feel like
i got
concerns for how some things are
happening but i think this is going to
be a good show
like you know and you know we're going
to we're gonna roll rotate a little bit
the dirt
dirt
yeah obviously last time we talked about
this it was before star filled and red
fall got delayed but now
since that info sat on your shoulders
for a couple weeks yeah
how
how is your expectations going into the
show now do you feel a little bit about
the same or is that completely changed
from the last time we did this show no
i'm actually even more excited you know
because
even though those games were delayed
they're still going to show those games
off
right and i'm
i'm i definitely want to see star field
and red fall is a game i was hyped for
because one i am a huge fan of arcane
studios
i finished uh all of the dishonored
games i haven't finished well i haven't
even played definite but trust me i will
play it as soon as no i can no i'm not
getting for the ps5 but so
um yes i'm
i'm super hyped about it even though uh
perfect dark and fable would not be
shown like you just said they have
announced so many projects like i
mentioned i love your analogy
yes we would like to see a couple more
projects you know maybe some new ips but
at the same time we want to see some
gameplay from some of those announced
games already right maybe a release
windows delete yeah yeah release windows
for
some of those announced games now we
know uh fable pervert boom put those to
the side maybe next year right but we
still have you know hellblade we have
capo what kubosa game hasn't been
announced but we know they've been
working on something so that's something
i would like to see there because even
though we happy few
it was a bit of a let
um
that game was originally crowdfunded
so but you see the talent there
and i can't wait to see what their their
title is going to be all we know when we
learn from like you guys show iron
lord's podcast that is a third-person
action game right then they say
something like that she said
third-person action so that's something
i want to see um
you know they have so much content
oh man in exile will they show up who
knows they're working on a huge aaa rpg
you know what else does but there's the
half
will a new doom be announced you know
these are all these these are a bunch of
different things that i'm like could
this happen could that happen and like i
said that wasn't always the case at xbox
shows
you know we always used to say
wait to e3 you know why you we used to
always say that at it because
some of us xbox guys we just assume
that's why i was going to show us
something because they didn't show us
anything the previous year
so wait to eat they're gonna show us
something then they wouldn't show us
nothing we have said that a lot of
really like oh brother listen i called
myself out i had a clip of myself saying
way to e3 over and out i put it on the
loop because i would say way to e3
weights e3 and yes we said it you should
they made fun of us but it was it was
what we was going through but
things are a little different now um so
i'm
man the show i'm extremely hyped for i
put out a tweet yesterday and i said i
haven't seen um you know randell thor
jess coordinates other guys dealer
say um
keep your expectations in check
he's like usually every year they'll say
something like that you know i don't
know if rand will hear hear some things
or jazz heard some things even tim dawg
you know our boy tim dawg he's super
high you know well tim dawg is always
hyped for the e3s or the big shows
so told me to keep my expectations in
check i don't even think like aaron
greenberg or anyone's come out like that
and said that like it's kind of weird
because if aaron feels like people
are over hyping something too much he's
the first people like whoa
whoa right all right i'm gonna need i'm
gonna need to see some ids okay get get
behind the door like
he's like chill y'all okay just chill
out qvs places and check so
that's definitely a positive thing um
but you know i thought they had a decent
show last year i thought they had a good
show last year you would like to see
more gameplay okay here we go this is
like a game like contraband that was
announced last year i would love to see
some gameplay from that this year you
know there were some other games that
they have some
some uh microsoft global publishing
games that's you know that's
being developed you know we heard about
all the rumors of project
midnight and project belfry and all that
other stuff so yeah these are some
things i'm interested in man but i do
want to see more gameplay of
some of the games like you said that the
doors have already been opened
i want to see some of this stuff with
windows with release windows
so yeah that's what i'm hype about man
and a couple of surprises would be good
i feel like you know we we what three or
four days from it now it's it's these
days we're close man and yeah
yeah
i was getting excited about this
around this time because it's just like
with gamers man
i i know people get tired of saying it's
like the christmas for gamers but it
really is like it really is man
because
now i honestly say it's even worse now
because i used to know what's going to
happen like
i used to literally have people pop in
and give me a list of the whole show
really there's a couple years where i
literally had a whole list of the whole
show sure it would be only be like a day
or two before it happened but it would
be a list of the whole show
i don't know and it was actually
anything it was accurate it sounds wow
yo yo yo dirt so sometimes it was an
order
really
it was an order man
like
one year i had how long they were
spitting on each one
wow
but this year nothing is legal nothing i
i can't that's good and i've i've even
snooped
and i can't open no one knows anything
wow
it's just it's
it's nice i i feel like we're we're
gonna get some good
uh game announcements uh you know good
game pass announcement you know we can
go into that a little bit you know uh
hustle
are you a subscriber to game pass do you
have that game pass ultimate
i don't have game plans ultimate but i
do have game pass on pc
so what what is an announcement that you
would personally want to see at this
show that's the the xbox but there's the
show
that
give that that says
coming to game pass day and day what
what's what's a game that you would like
to see on there
hey
well most of the games that i haven't
played i have the ability to play um a
game that i would like to see but i know
we won't see it is um river city girls
too we won't see that uh let's see what
the hell is that
do you wanna play river city girls
before
no it sounds like a portal to me man i
don't know what's going on no sir it's
not
a dope movie
this sounds like an adult movie to me
man what are you watching over there us
oh god
the other form no it's a beat em up game
it's a speedboat game um
oh i think i see i think i kind of think
i answered that question i would say
this i would say this
the gold now thing if they can get gold
now and this day one for game pass on pc
or even even on the xbox or whatever and
if i got to go out and buy xbox
i would just say
i would say put gold now over there
because that seems like that's halligan
that's highly anticipated for me because
that's what i'm looking forward to
i
okay dirk
so he he wants to first off do you think
golden i would be an exclusive
to pc and xbox like to me
the whole reason this happened is
because microsoft has worked with them
with nintendo to get the the license
they've had the license forever
so yeah i think it will be how people
would say well i don't think it's going
to be exclusive how is it not exclusive
microsoft worked to do out like yeah i
think people just assuming because it's
a james bond game it's not going to be
exclusive but like you just said i think
it's possible it could be exclusive man
let's let's go ahead and get these super
chats real quick before we move on to
the last
topic well we are on the last topic the
last segment of the topic yeah i find
out super chat from restored by life
uh by life uh why does why doesn't sega
just give their fans sonic avengers 3
instead of this unreal tech demo stuff
uh to be honest with you i wish sega
would just sell themselves to microsoft
and just be done with it
with you
i don't like look i'm not gonna say the
game isn't gonna be good maybe this is
something that we see now but when we
play in hindsight it makes sense i i
don't think that's gonna be the case
but you know i got i got to see more on
the game i got to see one i am going to
agree with you
i'm going to agree with you uh restored
it's definitely not looking good for
that game and then we got a two dollar
super chat from iron mike didn't
schreier leak one of the shows 30
minutes prior i don't know did he ever
do that i don't recall that i feel like
schreier would get
obliterated for that i remember one year
no denton schreier leaked the he he
leaked the release date in the trailer
for um for starkville didn't he wasn't
that him
yes like moments before it was almost
before it happened i do believe it was
literally like
what's funny is i started the the stream
because uh when when we do streams it's
all on uh i'm the one that does that
because carl don't know how to like make
the pictures uh like the kansas stuff
over the overlay so i i'm setting this
up i finish it
and i'm walking across the street with
my phone to get me something to drink to
you know pump me up before the show
and i get over there and i'm looking at
my phone all i see
is leaked leaked star feel trending star
feel trendy and i'm like
everything in me hustle and dirt
everything in me wanted to click that
and watch that trailer but i was like no
i made it this far damn it i ain't doing
that
and i i i did get the the
the date leaked uh because clearly you
can't avoid that he's literally using
the the 11 uh the eleven eleven uh
eleven thing on the screen they were
leaking that eleven eleven two twenty
two it was the thumbnail so you couldn't
avoid it you were just gonna get spoiled
man people people people are too much
sometimes man
all right so let's go ahead
dirt what's what's a game you think
could could hype people up for this game
pass day and date announcement should it
be
if they somehow
some way
oh god the way he's saying this is about
to be crazy because they could somehow
someone
like had a like god from knights
oh i think that's a i think that's a
given
oh you think you think this is that's
like going to happen i hope so that game
yeah look man i i ain't trying to speak
down on the game but i look at gotham
knights and i'm like
that game needs game pass yeah that's
got you know i'm not listening my boy on
on my podcast joey he's like that game
was great dirt and we have a uh a bet
i said the game would not be in the 80s
medicaid and he said it will so we're
not betting money i said whoever loses
got to drink a lot of like a raw egg on
air right with the camera on so no
so
um i don't think um i think yeah i think
that's the game because
because you know like the madden
rumor was debunked
i think gotham knights would be huge so
far
we don't know that's real
true
uh but i think that would be a huge
thing that'll give people hype if that
game was in game pass and i think a lot
more people would play it that didn't
plan on buying it
so yeah that's my answer got them nights
you know i'm about to surprise people
okay now
i don't
i think one we're going to see i i
ran
i'mma stand behind ran all this
and
if he ends up being wrong
ryan gonna look around he ain't gonna
see me okay like i'ma unless the stream
i'm gonna say i never stand with him at
all
i'm gonna stand behind rand and say
we're gonna get a final fantasy seven
remake
day date shadow drop for game pass and
i'ma say then they gonna turn around and
announce dead space is coming to game
pass day and day
hey let me tell you something right now
my friend
if those two things happen
that will be
huge
that would be huge absolutely okay no i
kind of forgot about uh a final fantasy
7 because i'm just not expecting this to
come to xbox ever
right but yeah that's that would be huge
you know would even be crazier and i
said this on the iop thing i don't know
this ain't gonna happen if they
announced
uh the final fantasy vii remake and then
score edix comes out and then now it's
part two on their stage
yo if that happens i'm gonna have a
heart attack we got a [ __ ] we got a two
dollar super chat from raiden blade
jason the rat man he is so hates xbox 20
minutes uh before
uh oh he's talking about the uh
starfield thing well i got no no no
problem with jason i do feel like
sometimes he's a little bit too
with certain stuff i you know but it is
what it is uh
he he's a good journalist though no
nothing look you can disagree with that
man but you can never take his his
journalists away from him he's put a lot
of work and he's a good journalist five
dollar super chat from gamer by choice
for dirt everyone hit the like button
yeah everybody
bro iop and wbg let's go
all right so love it
i feel like that is something that needs
that oh two dollars for that from flame
i just want to see dragon quest two and
three remake all right so let's let's go
let's go hustle real quick hustle you
wasn't here the last time i want to hear
your general thoughts of what you think
the show gonna be do you think it's
gonna be horrible are you to be clowning
it the whole time uh to be if you with
us don't be talking over the trailers
hustle don't be talking over the
trailers how do you think this is going
to happen
trust me i'll behave myself no i don't
think even though i'm still a little
worried about the perfect dog thing but
i don't think the show is going to be
bad i mean i think that
i think microsoft is in the unique or
xbox they're in a unique position the
way it's almost well i would say
impossible but it's damn near don't say
impossible i would say i would like to
say that because they have so much and
they have so so many ips and so much to
show like i kind of felt like you can't
fumble
that bag
you can't fumble it whichever way you go
whether you show stuff in the future
like playstation would do like four
years out whether you
give you know confirmed release dates on
the stuff that we know is coming out
whether you do stuff like that i don't
really feel like they can fail so i
think the show is going to be really
good i think
i think we kind of get a copy of what
happened last year you remember last
year but all the announcements was in
game pass and the show was like
extremely good i think we get i think if
we get a replay of that which isn't a
bad thing by the way i think we get a
replay of that though i think we hear
more about um nobody mentioned it but i
saw some things in regards to a halo
infinite i think that they kind of you
know if they
don't so certain things i think that
they'll go into detail in terms of like
hey
uh
august because it's rumored like i think
about three four three i think on the
halo way point i think it was like hey
it's rumored to uh drop the uh online
co-op
uh in august so i think we think we get
more stuff like that and it's kind of
impossible for yeah i know you said
don't say it but i'm gonna say anyway
it's kind of impossible for them to fail
in my opinion i don't think that if they
fail
i'm blaming you you getting all the
blame for it man
i think i think we might i don't think
we're seeing halo on the main stage i
don't i think it might be in the
extended show yeah it's true yeah i
don't think it's going to be in the main
stage like to me you're going to get a
lot of eyes on the main stage but you're
going to get a lot of eyes on the
extended stage and those are going to be
the hardcore people anyway you're going
to have a lot of casual people watch the
mainstream the main stage but a lot of
them aren't watching the extended one
and i think that's where that needs to
be dirt man
since
since
the starfield thing man
the dreadful day man the dreadful
thursday
where we showed offline on everything we
didn't pop up on anything we was taking
a day off on twitter you know you know
we we we was maybe signing out on
twitter i don't know it was a rough
couple of days it was a rough couple
days my brother so
do you think what is some of your
impressions on how this show is gonna go
now since they have because i will say
taking starfield
and and red fall out of the 2022 launch
window can change this whole show
yeah absolutely well first off you know
i haven't agreed with a lot what that
hustle said tonight but
i agree with i am going out on a limb
and i'm going to say it it's impossible
for them to have a bad show oh first off
when xbox
had no damn games but they still was
able to put on shows right now 2019 in
my opinion wasn't a great show
but
um they had decent shows in 2018 2017
and they had no games in development not
named halo gears of forza so for them to
have this much content in development
that they have announced
and a lot of content and development
that they haven't announced
there's no way this can be a bad show i
mean i just can't i know some places
this show is bad i'm blank if this show
is bad
i am single-handedly blaming you guys
it's like
like and i'm not even just a little bit
man you guys are jinxed in this how you
gonna come out and say there's no way
we ain't gonna listen about that
last last year's show like hustle said
was actually a pretty good show
this year
they might do something similar except
for with more gameplay a couple more
announcements
a few more games shown i just can't see
how this show can be bad i mean maybe
i'm just being the xbox or whatever but
i just can't see how this show can be
bad how could it be possible
that this show can be bad well they just
show a bunch of indies like 2019 was a
bad show to me right
it started off okay with a couple of the
multi-players keanu reeves came on on
stage and the show
went down for it was terrible the rest
of the show was terrible i was there
live for that too oh so
you got to witness it i was disgusted
man you know what's funny that was the
last like stage one like the one where
people went to i remember sitting there
that's the one with the deer the deer
game oh god
uh with the headlights oh man i'm
sitting there by the end of that show i
was disgusted with life i was let me
tell you something
i remember doing a youtube review after
that show fuming still i was still
steaming and i was like what and then
you like they showed gears but didn't
show campaign footage like what the
listen my point is
listen how can this show be back
okay i i know i don't like to use the
impossible word
but this is a different xbox
this isn't the same xbox this is a new
aggressive uh you know they know what we
want they know what what we us gamers
that's been waiting
show us gameplay
like i said they didn't show a lot of it
last year and this is a whole nother
year has gone by and i think they're
going to show more
and i've been gameplay pretty much
they're going to show game play like
they yeah
i was told you wanted the game play
you're going to get
gameplay money there's weight to e3
right yeah yeah
all right so
uh we got two more things to go over
real quick about this uh i want from
both you because now it's changed i feel
like this could change now what are they
beginning in this with because now since
star field isn't coming out this year
this could easily change we'll start
with hustle hustle what did they begin
this show with what they in the show
with the let me go on a little rant
people sit there and say added why do
you care because i feel like it matters
it matters all right they started with
something trash the whole show gonna be
trash if they hit it with something
trash the whole show gonna be trash
what they start with this and what they
especially they start they they man if
they start this that that deer game for
2019 we're going to have the same
conversation no
we want them to start it but they don't
i don't know
all right so hustle what are they we'll
start with star first i think that's
fair let's start with star first what
did they start this game with also this
this event what do they started with
somebody said it in the chat and i do
agree with them i still think they start
with starfield i think they start with
it and they announce that release date
when they start with it
i wholeheartedly agree with them i still
think they start with starfield with
actual gameplay this time
you know what
i'm i got to do something different
normally i'd agree with you guys you
know i'm going to go with the pack but i
ain't going with the pack this time i'm
going to say they start with a valve
oh
that's a good one though that would be
good they start with a valve yeah i feel
like uh that that that is the
correct answer you guys are the wrong
but that's the correct answer
you know they can start
we will revisit this sir
all right we're gonna talk about who was
wrong and who was right next week all
right be there because i'm gonna be
right and if i'm wrong i'm still right
all right so so okay you guys
you guys two were saying star phone i'm
saying a vow you're probably to be right
there i'm not going to write a lie uh
but i am right because it's my show so
that's just how it goes
uh so all right so now what are they
ending this with what are they going to
do
we're going to start with let's start
with dirt what are they ending this with
okay
i think
they could possibly end with what you
think they're going to start with
oh you know i
i said a new ip right uh unannounced ip
no you know i'm going to stick with an
unannounced ip
oh
all right what
yeah i i was thinking about but i'm
going to say this it's going to end with
an unannounced ip
you get two points if you can guess it
but if you try to guess it you don't get
any points that's how i'm uh
i'm going to say
that mm-hmm
project
i don't know if that project drag is
gonna be ready to be shown
one of those project games
what is project midnight oh no that's
compulsion right compulsions project
midnight project midnight i'm going to
see fantasies the one by owl interactive
uh okay kuta whatever that one is the
one by certain infiniti
all right so so he going with a new ip
you know something code name project
which they're all code name project but
we ain't going into that so hustle yeah
what are they ending the show with what
are they gonna go and we got one more
thing for you what's it gonna be hustle
someone said elder scrolls six game play
you are out of your mind brian game what
are they ending this with uh hustle
um in the words of pem c you know the
same way we're gonna start it it's the
same way we're gonna end it
for those who all who don't know what
i'm talking about they ended with
hellblade 2 when the release date in my
opinion i think they in the the same way
they started it with when they revealed
the xbox series x and they said hey we
got one more thing i think they
i think they put a ball on that and i
think you know that that may come out
sometime next year i think you know that
i think that would work that would be
dope with a release day too that'd be
fine
you know what i feel strongly about that
one yes sir you don't think they're
gonna end it with
what's that they're gonna do with a vow
you know
look at the end of the day i feel like
to go into with one of them so i feel
like i'm gonna be right on one end right
on the other and if they flip them
around
you guys are wrong on both then i went
either way well i'm joking i'm joking
i'm joking um
i think i think they end with kojima's
game
oh
he comes out uh and he says
i'm going to
uh be working with microsoft uh here's
our new yp and he's going to play his
game now look look you guys
is that what it's called
well that leaks yeah overdose that's the
name of the game oh well you guys know
how i feel about kojima i feel like his
games don't really resonate in games i
feel like he should probably be a movie
producer more director or something over
there but i do know his name holds white
and uh i feel like if he's microsoft's
able to get him on board and
they're ending his show it's going to be
ended with his game like a huge i don't
i don't see around where they get kojima
maybe they'll open with it i don't know
uh but i feel like you end it
you come out there you say
we got one more thing for you they leave
kojima pops up on the screen he goes to
some probably promotes one of his
friends movies
but then he's going to show his new game
it's going to get labeled as an xbox
exclusive slash pc
and then the world on twitter is going
to melt let me say you set them up you
know hold up you know would be crazy if
he has got the death stranding 2 license
and that's shown here oh wow don't don't
say that
let me tell you something
if that happens what you just described
addict with kojima
i'm literally taking off the week for
work
just to talk on twitter
real quick let me let my dogs win this
it's starting to rain outside oh you're
fine you're fine
i
i personally feel like this year is a
very good year for microsoft look i i
don't think they're going to
oh god please don't let me down like
there is like there's like three there's
levels to this you know we got to get
him on here man i got to get him on here
there's levels to this all right there's
that level
yeah doctor
there's that level we come in here we're
like yo
they they did they think not really you
know it is what it is it was a good show
but then there's that yo it's a good
show man like i feel like i was i was
sad it's funny it's like
they did it
yeah they did it
and i feel like i want them to be in
that middle one and that's where i would
i want them on the top man i want them
more we're all just like they did it
but
i feel like microsoft b and microsoft
and you know uh i don't know if they're
gonna get that so i'm hoping at least in
the middle man at least in the middle it
is a new xbox i mean it isn't the same
old xbox from last year
it started you know
i think that's the because i i do want
to ask both of you uh obviously you said
yours but it might have changed there
what's that game what's that
announcement you don't want to see
what's that announcement that you see
and you automatically going to give them
they i guess i guess they did their
thing like
so you saying the one-eyed dumb like uh
like so if i see it
what immediately say oh what's that
announcement that you like this is the
bathroom break
anything sea of thieves related
i think that's my answer before too
anything because i know they're going to
show some cfds with
anything see
with minecraft
yeah yeah so yeah i'm just like okay
yeah i know it's coming uh
hurry up you know
i don't know hustle you there
yes sir what is that announcement
that you see
and you'd be like okay i gotta use the
bathroom right now man i don't need to
watch this this bull uh what's that one
that you do not want to see at this
event
ooh
you know i try to keep opening i know
it's gears gears right that's what
that's what you don't want to see at
this advanced gear all right okay let's
let's slow down let's slow down um if if
i had to pick one thing that you would
mention that earlier but we and i'll say
it because we won't see it that's
turning into i'll just say because we
won't see it now i always try to keep an
open mind about stuff like that though
like i try not to
sleep on nothing because
i feel like nothing is you know people
work hard on that stuff and i can
appreciate the fact that people work
hard on that um
i wish you would have hit me with that
question before like a few hours earlier
i could have really thought about
i'll be honest with you i can't i can't
really
i don't know
i couldn't tell you
i could i couldn't tell you he's always
trying to feel open-minded about stuff
like that
okay and keynote chat feel free to put
it in there too i don't know
yeah i don't know if we'll have time to
read any of them uh because it is going
a little longer than i normally like got
to play with this two dollar super chat
bathroom break for me is kojima
yo flame is ridiculous okay here's how i
feel about it okay
i
am scared to death that they're gonna
feel like since starfield's been delayed
they're like we could show starfield
later we don't need to show big presence
of star field starfield come at the
video game awards for all i care i'm
scared they're gonna have that mentality
that since it's been delayed they're
gonna show a delayed game and uh i'm
scared for that i want a seat and i feel
like if
they could have an amazing show but if
they don't show us a decent amount on
star field people are going to
automatically deem it out look at behind
dirt bird dirt literally has the xbox
but that's the game
show behind him and it's themed after
star field if these people don't show
star field like i i'm gonna be i'm gonna
be upset
now uh then we got the adjacent man
what's uh clearly hustle yours is gears
right something that they announced it's
just gonna make you excited happy don't
really matter to anyone next to you
screw everyone next to you i don't care
if they don't like what's that one
announcement that you'll be like yo
they they did right by me maybe not
right by everybody but they did right by
me dir what is yours
um
you know what i would
for them to do right by me
see these two right
absolutely not but
a new killings thing
they would say they did they did not
just me right but
us
xbox gamers and not just if that
happened
it could be two years away like you just
want to see this announcement just
announce that they're making it yeah if
they did that i'd have to go watch if k
mega is streaming this right here
yeah you're going to go crazy man
yeah it was it's a solid game man um so
yeah they will blow xbox you get you did
not just me right you did us xbox games
right all right so hustle what's that
game man is it gears is that what we're
gonna say
uh yeah get guess is is the quick answer
perfect doc will be like another one but
they probably won't show that
uh ah hell i'll just take a shot in the
dark i'll see pro-am they i know they're
not gonna show that but
[Laughter]
i'll see pro-am that's just for me like
i said that's red that's red i i i i
that's the first game i've ever played
man i mean i you know because everybody
knew that was going to be guests
everybody know that that's that that's
what that answer is going to be for me
so i want to switch i do want to switch
it up a little bit
if they
if they give me remember that game
if they give me like a remake of fable
or fable collections
that would be mine like i could honestly
say or you know uh uh fallout 3
collections or fallout collections in
general or fallout 3 remake
that would be mine i would get a lot of
hype behind that you know give me uh you
know final fantasy if that happens
persona announcement that happens but if
they announced that they bought sega
then you would officially have me
flipping [ __ ] so it's the last one man
right now we don't know we don't know
what's gonna happen i feel like we all
assume this is gonna be a good show uh
but one to ten what do you think you're
gonna write this show sunday one to ten
hustle would you gonna write this show
on your mind out of what you see now
what does you think you won't end up
ranking the show you think it's gonna be
a mid show i think it's gonna be a good
show what is your assumptions and what
number you're gonna give this show as of
right now well i'll say if it's anything
based off of the
predictions that we that i had earlier
like i would have to give it a nine
either nine or ten because if it was if
it's anything like last year
how it was you know everything kept
coming and it was like a really good
show last year if it's anything like
last year then i would have to give it a
nine
time what you're gonna be dirt you're
gonna say 10 is it 10.
i'm i'm wrote a 9 or a 10. it's like
russell said yeah because i gave last
year's show like a 8.5 so i think this
show is going to be better than that so
i think i'm going to give it eight i
think uh right now i think they're gonna
do what they need to do
uh there's obviously stuff they can do
they give me any kind of favor it's
gonna be ten out of ten anything
favorable you get ten out of ten that's
that's the loss microsoft you want
addict to give you a ten out of 10. i'm
easily bribable by the way you know my
paypal i'm joking
look if they give me some kind of fable
man i i i you know might go a little bit
more to the right but you know
eight out of ten i hope it's a 9 10 item
that's a fantastic score i hope they i
hope they show up man
show us game play show us good stuff
with star field good stuff of a vow show
us you know maybe a fable remake you
know you know
come on man come on man banjo-kazooie
with some game play once they announced
the badger kazumi that coming out this
year
i think that'd be cool once it they
never like it
once it's if if it's his been rumored
someone is making a killing scene coming
out this year
that'd be fine yeah so it is what it is
man we got two dollars from uh apollo
copper cooper uh paula cooper
teasing about apology fighter i hope man
i hope that's the dude from um
another realm right oh yeah yeah so i
hope man
i hope you guys enjoyed the prediction
show that we had a little bit of a we
got to get we got we had to get hustle
man we had to get hustles things right
before the show
the show will be sunday and uh you know
i'm pretty sure hustle gonna be
streaming with us where are you gonna be
streaming dirt are you gonna be
streaming with someone
yeah absolutely uh on my channel we're
gonna be streaming wbg all the homies at
wbg we're going to be streaming um you
know having a good old time then after
the show we're going to go to my boy
sean 786 channel i guess we're calling
the after show after party toss some
trash there and uh yeah maybe i have a
good old time bro
now you know it'll be crazy if it's so
bad you don't do that after party
because if it's bad yeah we're gonna do
that
people say you know what i'm just about
to cut off the logo yeah i'm tired man
let me get something to eat
exactly
we got a two dollar super shot from
orowolf uh
attic was doing lunch with microsoft man
[ __ ] i wish i was doing with lunch with
mike because babe let me tell you right
now all right if i'm doing lunch with
microsoft don't be don't be calling me
all right i mean i'm eating steak on a
dollar i'm eating lobster and they dolla
i'm eating all kinds of stuff on their
dog you know it's going to be different
it's going to be different if i go in
there and stuff i'll be looking at that
looking at the price point bringing up
my phone do a little catchy later if
it's microsoft's dime i'm just ordering
not looking at nothing just i want this
i want that i want this my plate my side
of the table is going to look
vegetarian or whatever you want to
pronounce that i don't know man it's
going to look luxurious it's going to
look great
it's going to look amazing you're going
to look at my thing
it's going to look like something
someone is promoting their business on
my side of the table man it's going to
be so full i ain't going to be able to
fit my phone it's going to go in my
pocket like my pocket right here this
time you're gonna fit on the table i
appreciate ever coming through man dirt
where can they find you man where can
they can find you uh
my channel dirt griggity you know i have
a lot of fun over there i'm definitely
pro xbox most playstation fanboys won't
like my channel but it's okay
um so stop on by man
uh yes it's i'm gonna leave it in the uh
you might put the link in there yeah
yeah
oh yeah
yeah so i'm gonna leave the link um guys
thanks yeah yeah well i stopped on by
man you know we had the time over there
okay
you what you you what's funny is when i
see your your your little skits on your
channel man i'm like yo
you know you kind of remind me of you
kind of remind me of like
a different version of z uh how he does
his like weird stuff man like like you
guys are like one but i didn't think
anyone else done stuff like z but then i
started watching your stuff like yo this
this content funny it difficult yeah man
yeah we have kind of clip skits we just
you know i don't know if you've ever
seen what i did at the crime like
playstation man baby i don't know if you
see when i do that or not i do a voice
over i mean something funny man before i
know we have fun you know we talk trash
but we also talk gaming news we talk
about you know what's going on in the
industry we talk about what's going on
in our community
you know so yeah we have a good time man
see there there's realms to the crumb
side
like like you got the you got the bottom
bottom you know the people that fall go
all the way straight to the bottom you
got them
then you got like the little step
the couple steps up you know you see
it's like it's like you got this giant
hole that a meteor made years ago
and that's that's the crump side and
then you know then you got the the
society on the outskirts that's the
people that make good money that the you
know they don't worry about them then
you got like the giant castles in the
corner you know those are like the
millions and millions of subs then you
got the crumb side of the middle and the
crims side it varies it's big man it's a
lot of real estate there's a lot of real
estate down there but the farther you
get down the darker it is and then once
you get to a certain further down in the
crumb side you gotta just kind of start
swinging man you gotta walk and swing
because you can't see nothing you gotta
walk and swing but you know i would say
dirt dirt at that point man where you
know he can easily reach his hand up and
touch the top but he don't want to be at
the very top man he want to be in a
little bit in the middle
yeah i mean you know i like kind of you
know
roughing the fellas feathers a little
bit because you know back in the day
when i wasn't doing console wars stuff
had a much smaller channel i still have
people coming after me talking trash
anyway so
you know at the end of the day man
the good thing about being in that that
crater that the media made years once
upon a time ago that's created the crumb
side is if you're in that crater you're
uncancelable
you can't be cancer
like yo
yo yo yo see you can only be canceled at
the people following you care and i can
honestly and i can 100 tell you guys
they don't care
but i appreciate everyone coming through
man hustle where can they find you out
man
i mean they can find me um well i tell
you what you can't find me you can't
find me on the crime side y'all y'all
got that one yeah i'ma let y'all hold
that down that ain't my thing that is
not my thing whatsoever see i'm not on
the crumb side either we we we talking
like you know i i have this this little
like this little campfire at the very
top right next to the stairs man right
next to the stairs going to the crumb
side you know if i want to i stroll down
there and you know see
see what dirt's doing man he he neighbor
he a neighbor like like you know he and
neighbor in the crump side but i'm not
in the crump side because i'm not
allowed to be unfortunately so you know
i'm just visiting
i say this man look i i should be back
it shouldn't be a problem but i should
be back saturday with the live stream um
i'll probably go over this topic you
know treat it like a robbery i get in
and get you out on my channel hustling
motivate on youtube uh follow me on
twitter too i'll be uh i have fun over
there on twitter every so often
and i really kick it and have a good
time um
slow-mo
christ i was trying to find slow-mo's
channel y'all make sure y'all check out
the dps podcast as well every thursday
at 8 30
p.m eastern standard time well now about
p.m eastern standard time between game
and forte and slow mo backslash channel
y'all make sure y'all check them out
i'll have a video on sunday and it's my
last of us play through so
there y'all go uh you'll see that for
the next i say month and a half
so there we go um i'm good i'll see
y'all wait i'll i'll see y'all again
what sunday right yeah i'll see you on
sunday i probably i probably won't have
a stream chat in there so i'll see y'all
something on this channel i'll be
channel
double flying literally just came out
openly he said because boom put was
double fine showing off something maybe
i don't know badger kazooie double fight
said no
[Laughter]
yo you have to
you gotta have some balls to come out be
like we ain't gonna be there fam
at least give the people the illusion of
hope double fine
they're like no ain't gonna be that fan
fam sit down sit down ain't no banjo
kazooie coming from us sit the hell down
boom but i love that i love that you
know appreciate we're going to see we'll
be back next week with the receipts on
me being right uh appreciate ever coming
through man we add up to like 460 70
people in here hit that like button i
like to get it above 200 before the end
of the show got nine likes man i'm sure
there's nine of you in here that's been
watching this on your phone
we're doing whatever you do and i don't
know maybe some of you supposed to be
working but you ain't but that's okay we
in the you know we we we good we ain't
snitches in these we don't snitch i'm
sure we can get that easily above 200
it's four likes man four of you people
have been able to like this one podcast
there's two lights let's go two more
lights here we go there we go now we can
in the park
thank you all i get to go to sleep now
thank you all i appreciate every coming
through and uh you know like i said
follow both of these uh i will say that
the ilp you know the crew will be
reacting to the aisle to the xbox
prediction
show well xbox but that is the
prediction show and until next week
until the receipts show up that is
saying i was right on everything we'll
see you next week okay all righty all
right y'all
all right